but I actually wanted to to Really make
this this point clear there is no one
way to do science Dave like you asked me
in the beginning about science there is
no science says or follow this there's
not even science like science uh is
essentially basically a you know a
shortcut a hack for us unraveling
fundamental truths that never is perfect
is guaranteed to be imperfect
Sheldon glass show the nucleator
Shelley or Sheldon glass show so he's
the namesake inspiration for the Big
Bang uh theories uh Sheldon a young
Sheldon Sheldon
um he's a throwback to he's an older guy
and and he really you know made his way
doing something quite unique my wife
told me last night she was reading it
and yeah I wrote another book before
this I'm not convinced she read that
book Dave don't tell her I said so
although she's a big fan of yours so she
she'll be disappointed to know if you
read that first book and not this anyway
so she was reading last she said like
appropriate because what he would
covered like um the discovery that
electricity and magnetism and Technical
physics terms are basically two
different aspects of one underlying
physical law and that's called
electromagnetism so that you can turn a
small current can move a motor and spin
a motor you could also spin that motor
and generate a current that's in fact
how currents and electrical power
generation Works
um so he discovered the analog of that
unification in What's called the nuclear
force it's not super important to get
into but it really delineated how these
things that we perceive very different a
magnet that you put on your refrigerator
and uh you know and a nine volt battery
they seem very different but they are
different manifestations of the same
underlying coin he did so with his
colleagues Stephen Weinberg and Abdul
Salam in the 60s and 70s they discovered
a similar feature of uh the nuclear
force and my wife was reading and she's
like this is so interesting because what
one person perceives as a manifestation
say pure electricity another will
perceive as magnetism or as one person
agencies as electricity will see as a
nuclear force that's so interesting
because could could you imagine Dave as
you do often and you talk about in your
book can you argue the other person's
side can you do that because otherwise
as you and said I might like debate is
kind of pointless like oh Joe Biden did
a great you know debating with Trump I'm
going to vote for him now is it die hard
no that never happened but if you can
say I see your perspective right and
literally it is just as kosher just as
good as another person's perspective
well then why not use that as a metaphor
for how we could be maybe a little less
polarized so I like that she got I
wasn't intending to say that um but but
it did come out and uh from her
interpretation of reading this chapter
about how things that appear so
different Dave are really the same
manifestation of of of the underlying
same phenomenon we actually could use a
little bit more of that in politics I'm
sure I could use a little bit more of it
personally as well uh then there's an
interstitial should we go into the
interstitial why do you throw an
interstitial into the book
what's going on here I got paid by the
word it's a short book you know and it's
it's not there's no physics equations
there's no homework uh you know although
you you know you being a master Quantum
electrodynamics would have done quite
well if there were exactly I had Uh
custom illustrations and I should say I
have a podcast where I give away all
these interviews you don't have to buy
the I hope you will I hope you'll get
the audio or the or the printed book but
um but I actually wanted to to Really
make this this point clear there is no
one way to do science Dave like you
asked me in the beginning about science
there is no science says or follow this
there's not even science like science uh
is essentially basically a you know a
shortcut a hack for us unraveling
fundamental truths that never is perfect
is guaranteed to be imperfect and so to
some of us gives great comfort because
you can never get the right answer in
other words Newton was darn smart and he
is responsible for the laws that take
Elon Musk SpaceX to the to the stars and
took the Apollo Astronauts to the
surface of the Moon but if you want to
go go and understand the properties of a
black hole his work will not do and you
need Einstein well guess what Einstein's
not the right answer either we're going
to find some subsequent Improvement to
it maybe quantum gravity which will you
know we'll get it we have a 10-part
learning company series you and I on
that so we can refer people to that
lecture series
and guess what that won't be the final
answer either so I want to show that
there's different approaches to arriving
at truth you can manifest them I was
talking to uh Tom bilya who lives in La
is a famous podcaster great guy I had
him on the show I was actually at his
laboratory and he told me his way that
he works through you know when he was at
Quest Nutrition and he was developing
these really tasty but nutritious bars
protein bars whatever and the scientific
method that he was using and how he also
applies it to venture capital or to now
he's into nfts and Bitcoin and stuff
like that but it's a it's a process of
thinking guaranteed to be imperfect but
better than all the rest so I want to
outline how you can do it my avatar is a
is a car salesman in Tulsa Oklahoma
um it's not a scientist it's not written
for science science majors and that you
can apply methodological thinking
testing hypotheses listening to your
critics achieving consensus and
realizing in surreptitiously perhaps
that when you hear things like 99 of
scientists agree you should be very
concerned you should be very we hear an
awful lot about that these days uh on
many fronts actually not just covid
climate change all sorts of things uh
Carl Wyman the teachers teacher
yeah so for a long time I had been kind
of an acolyte of Malcolm Gladwell uh who
you know popularized he didn't invent
this this uh this this concept but the
so-called ten thousand hour rule so I
did a little math you've been doing
podcasting uh the Reuben report been on
you know 2000s early 2000s you've had
way more than ten thousand hours but the
study that Gladwell and uh and Anders
Erickson popularized was that basically
the best Pilots have 10 000 hours of
flight experience Bill Gates had like 10
000 hours of computer programming by the
time Microsoft Steve Jobs had ten
thousand so he done it's basically it's
not a scientific analysis it's really
correlative
um and I wanted to know well we as
professors we never really get taught
how to teach it's very rare you may be
interested in teaching in pedagogy but
we have so many other obligations in
addition to teaching research funding uh
bureaucracy you know and and getting
through you know all the different Hoops
of working not just at a State
University and a university
um and then teaching is on there and
it's a big priority it's the reason we
get into it but oftentimes we're
distracted by other quotidian demands
and in this case I wanted to kind of
demystify how should we be teaching
because I don't know if you know it but
the way that we teach with like some
dude scraping a piece of rock on another
piece of rock that is almost exactly a
thousand year old model it's not been
disrupted since the year 1080 in Bologna
Italy when the first modern University
Incarnation came along where you'd have
some guy you know and but the only thing
that's better now is that back then Dave
the students could go on strike and the
professors would not get paid so thank
God we have tenure I mean that you know
that's barbaric that is a barbaric
practice but other than that what has
changed so I got into all sorts of
things could we have an artificial
intelligent Professor could we alleviate
some of the the burden but also free up
the the minds and the time of the
student to do it and he likened our
current practice of teaching to the
medical practices is of the 18th and
17th century with leeches and
bloodletting he said we're at a
primitive State and we need to go beyond
that he has some models to do it I don't
think any of them are foolproof but the
key takeaway I took Dave is that
to be a good teacher you have to be a
student of teaching and I pointed out in
the book uh that the word scientist in
the Russian language means someone who
was taught to me that conveys an
obligation you both have to be a good
student but you have to be a good
teacher to pay it forward to the next
generation and so I think he exemplifies
that to me and really made me want to
double down and be a better teacher by
studying teaching and that's not
something I really have that much time
to do but I find a little bit of effort
goes a long way with it and I hope in
anybody's field the way to learn
something to be a better salesman to be
a better podcaster I think I asked you
when you came out I was like how do you
know Dave when you're giving a good
interview when you're doing a good job
as an inner like there's no like you
don't have a grader anymore but you must
study it and you must listen to it and
even if that means studying with people
that maybe you don't agree with all the
time you can learn a lot and that's part
of the humble uh you know nature that I
think it takes to be a good student and
Ergo a good teacher if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversation about Academia instead of
non-stop yelling check out our Academia
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell